para la Unión Europea las fugas es
simultáneas de los gasoductos
que conecta Rusia hasta Europa no es un
no es ninguna coincidencia todos los
indicadores parecen señalar de que se
tratan de un acto deliberados y lo
asegurado el alto representante para la
política exterior de la Unión Europea
josep borrell ha avanzado que también
todas las infraestructuras energéticas
consideradas sensibles en la Unión
Europea van a ser vigiladas y van a
reforzarse esta vigilancia también la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
fonder Legend Ya habla abiertamente de
que se trata de un Sabotaje y que todo
merece una investigación a cuanto antes
también lo asegura si el secretario
general de la otan James toltenberg que
después de reunirse esta mañana con el
ministro de defensa danés también habla
ya abiertamente de Sabotaje las
instituciones europeas aseguran que la
respuesta va a ser contundente que va a
ser fuerte ahora mismo se está
discutiendo ya un octavo paquete de
sanciones algo sabía previsto desde la
semana pasada tras los recientes
anuncios de Vladimir Putin de los
considerados referéndums ilegales y
también estás amenazas nucleares estás
estas sanciones principalmente van a ser
económicas hay que ver cuáles va a ser
exactamente el nivel de ambición porque
hay mucho temor de que se pueda
resquebrajar la unidad de los 27 en este
nuevo paquete de sanciones Así que es
algo que habrá que ver pero la Unión
Europea quiere atacar aumentar la
presión a Rusia en un momento en que el
régimen está especialmente bajo ahora
mismo lo cierto Es que de confirmarse
este Sabotaje es un paso más en esta
tensión entre Europa y Rusia y Se
confirma que el gas se está utilizando
se está utilizando como un arma más en
esta guerra donde hemos sobre ese tema
que decía anteriormente esté recordemos
que el día de ayer se llevó a cabo
digamos este últimos referendos de las
regiones separatistas por rusias en
territorio ucraniano algo que por
supuesto rechazo occidente y también la
Unión Europea y se espera que el
presidente de la Emir Putin este viernes
pues confirme no y asuma lo que dijo
supuestamente que habría ganado el Sí en
estas zonas pero las reacciones de la
Unión Europea en torno a esto que está
ocurriendo
sí la respuesta de la Unión Europea ha
sido un ánimo un referéndum falso con
resultados falsos no se va a reconocer a
ninguno de los dos Así lo asegurado el
presente del Consejo europeo Charles
Michel para la Unión Europea todo es una
farsa y no se va a reconocer en absoluto
el jefe de la diplomacia europea josep
borrell asegura que todo se trata de una
violación más por parte de Rusia de la
soberanía de Ucrania que por lo tanto no
se va a respetar que todo va a ser como
hasta ahora y que todo es territorio
ucraniano en cualquier caso es una
muestra más de que el diálogo entre
Rusia y la Unión Europea va a ser cada
vez más difícil porque estos referendos
de hecho complican aún más la situación
y una solución pacífica en algún futuro
cercano